Sister Mary Janice is the director of
the response to love Center in Buffalo
New York the center offers hot meals and
guidance to neighborhoods around it but
on a Saturday morning early this month
thieves tried to rob the center you're
seeing the footage on your screen right
now
so Sister Mary Janice responded
immediately she went outside and she saw
the thieves setting up a ladder she
prayed as she kicked the ladder and the
thieves ran away
Sister Mary Janice is a nun and a leader
at the response to love Senator needless
to say she's also our employee of the
month she joins us tonight sister
Chinese we are honored to have you on
tonight your response to this burglary
amazes me can you just describe what
happened
well it happened I was tossing with
wrestling with God because I wanted to
sleep a little longer on Saturday but
something told me to get up
so I got up set on green Emerald Island
that's my chair where I pray and I sat
there for an hour in prayer and I said
I'll go down now have breakfast with my
two sisters walk down the stairs and I
heard some noise I thought maybe it's
the newspaper or someone driving down
and I opened up the door and I saw this
step ladder and I said oh this step
ladder doesn't belong here no workers
here on a Saturday close the door again
and I thought I gotta move that ladder
the light went on when I opened the door
and one of the fellas ran away
the next when I looked up he was on the
roof and I said he's got to come down
but not on this ladder so by the grace
of God grabbed the ladder threw it down
looked up and the fellow jumped down
Stood Beside Me and I said this is God's
Property this is God's Mission how dare
you do this
I pointed my finger and I told him get
out and he ran away and that's how the
story ended but then I wondered this was
God's mission for me and there's a
lesson in all this you know there was no
violence no one was hurt I wasn't hurt
and maybe a lesson was to be learned and
I think that's what happened not only
for me not only for them but I think for
the whole world to say you know there is
a God and we're here to protect him and
his mission and that's what happened
well you're an amazing person were you
afraid at all
no I wasn't afraid at all because I knew
it was something that had to be done you
know we're working in an area that's
very poor and I'm no different than
anybody who's there
subject to looting theft violence and
I'm in that neighborhood and I have an
identity that I share with my people I'm
no better and no different I want to be
there and the building that we're in is
special it's a dining room it's a place
of safety people coming together
enjoying a meal and just experiencing so
much joy
why would someone want to hurt that
mission
amen Sister Mary Janice great to see you
tonight thank you for coming on the show
it's just an experience of God
it's an experience where
God Is So present he wants that mission
to reach out to poor people
to really share that their loved
compassion you know in our building we
don't have a lot of money
we raise all the money we do all the
service to make it special for people
well I have the feeling this is going to
help your fundraising I hope it does and
I appreciate your coming on thank you
you know God does provide for us but so
many people really join in
they help us so beautifully they're
always there for us with donations of
clothing
donations of food
monetary gifts
I black You Are Not Afraid Sister Mary
Jennings thank you very much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight